today's video is kindly sponsored by
policy genius find out more later in the
video hey 42 here when you meet someone
new what's the first thing you learn
about them perhaps it's that they're
allergic to seafood or that they only
drink single malt whiskey with two ice
cubes and a straw but more often than
not it's going to be their name and
these simple monikers affect more than
just our first impressions there's a
growing body of evidence suggesting that
our names can influence our
personalities our careers our health and
even our love lives so
what's in a name quite a lot apparently
in the 1990s readers of new scientist
magazine began to notice that a
surprising number of scientific studies
were carried out by researchers with
remarkably well-suited surnames
there was a book on polar exploration by
daniel snowman
an article on incontinence by splat and
whedon
and a subterranean guide to london by
richard trench these anecdotes led to a
theory that people tend to gravitate
towards careers that fit their names
and as the reports flooded in the
magazine decided to give this phenomenon
a name of its own
nominative determinism
one area where nominative determinism
has already been well documented is
healthcare
largely thanks to studies carried out by
the esteemed doctors
lim
lim lim
and lim
inspired by the fact they shared a
rather fitting surname themselves the
four limbs decided to see whether
healthcare-related surnames cropped up
in the medical profession more often
than would be expected through chance or
circumstance alone and it turns out they
very much do
if you have someone who relies on your
financial support whether it's a child
an aging parent or even a business
partner you need life insurance policy
genius makes it super easy to compare
quotes from over a dozen top insurers
all in one place meaning you could save
50 percent or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius and
that's because the licensed experts at
policy genius work for you
not the insurance companies that kind of
service has earned policy genius
thousands of five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google the best part is
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week that's why this
exclusive policy was recently rated
number one by forbes advisor so how does
it work well first you need to head over
to www
pull
forward slash 42
and in minutes you can work out how much
life insurance coverage you actually
need and compare personalized quotes to
find your best price
then when you're ready to apply the
policy genius team will handle the
paperwork and scheduling for free policy
genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
a particularly strong trend for
job-related names was found in urology
an area of medicine concerned with the
urinary tract and male reproductive
organs
where the limbs found an abundance of
dicks and balls there was even a
texas-based vasectomy specialist called
dr dick shop and if that's not a
self-fulfilling prophecy i don't know
what is examples of nominative
determinism exist outside of the
sciences too look at usain bolt the
record-breaking sprinter or su-u
an aptly named lawyer from america then
there's mr phillin he's a substitute
teacher and rich richie who's an
investment banker and it's not just
people's jobs that seem to be affected
consider vania stambleover the bulgarian
athlete who stumbled over the first
hurdle of her 400 meter sprint at the
london olympics in 2012
or
will drop the montreal window cleaner
who died in a fall on the same day will
drop dropped to his death
inmates will burn and frizzle were sent
to the electric chair now i have to
admit i am kind of cherry-picking here
for every athlete doctor lawyer and
criminal with a seemingly perfect name
there are probably hundreds if not
thousands without the most common
doctor's name in britain is khan which
means noblemen and in the usa it's patel
which means village chief or farmer and
while some people do seem to follow
their name-based destiny plenty of
others have done exactly the opposite
including archbishop cardinal james sin
and danielle outlaw the philadelphia
police commissioner so clearly your name
doesn't set your fate in stone still
naming your child is a lot of pressure
and despite the thousands of baby naming
books and websites out there studies in
britain have shown that one in five
parents
regrets the names they chose for their
children perhaps that has something to
do with the recent rise in parents
opting for quirky and unusual baby names
but it turns out that giving your baby a
truly mental name isn't a modern
phenomenon dreamt up by celebrities with
too much time on their hands
with the exception of a few eccentrics
like elon musk and grimes who named
their son ex aexie
most parents today don't even come close
to religious reformers the puritans for
cursing their children with truly
appalling names
court records from 1609 indicate that a
certain kill sin pimple of sussex
served on a jury with his neighbors fly
debate roberts
more fruit fowler
fight the good fight white and stand
fast on high stringer if there's one
sure-fire way to get your child atomic
wedgied on their first day in school
it's giving him the first name fly
debate back in the 1600s surnames were
still a relatively new phenomenon at
least in europe they were brought in by
william the conqueror to make it easier
for him to tax landowners and they only
became hereditary in england in the mid
14th century surnames usually came from
either the father's name
the family occupation
a characteristic like being tall or a
location so if your surname is farmer
chances are your ancestors worked on a
farm
this could perhaps go some way to
explaining nominative determinism
after all if you come from a family of
farmers you're probably more likely to
become a farmer yourself
but family history can only explain so
much especially when it comes to first
names for example the number of dentists
called dennis is significantly higher
than would be expected based on the
frequency of that name in the general
population
and a similar trend can be seen for
denise's dinas denny's and denver's the
most common explanation for this odd
correlation is something psychologists
call implicit egotism
in other words we really love ourselves
and therefore tend to gravitate towards
anything that reminds us of us our
unconscious bias towards things that
make us think of ourselves also seems to
exert some level of influence over other
aspects of our lives besides just our
choice of career from where we live
to who we love
for example there are a surprisingly
high number of virginias in virginia
jacks in jacksonville and louise in
saint louis
although this could just as easily be
down to parents naming their children
after where they're born rather than
people actively choosing to live in
cities and states that sound like their
names
implicit egotism can also affect your
dating prospects
it's been shown that people using dating
gaps are more likely to swipe right on
people whose names sound more similar to
their own or at the very least start
with the same letter so far i focused on
how our names might be subtly dictating
the paths we choose throughout life
but there is another side to all of this
our names also influence how others see
us the sad truth is that people with
unfashionable names are more likely to
be rejected socially than those with
trendy ones at least according to
several studies over the last decade or
so even the way our names sound can
affect how people think of us and
good or bad this can have a pretty
significant impact on both our behavior
and our interactions with society as a
whole look at these two characters
one's called booba and the others called
kiki
one's more outgoing the other is more
introverted
which one do you think is which
there's a very good chance you picked
kiki to be the spiky character
most people do that might not seem like
much of a big deal but think about what
that means subconsciously we seem to
associate certain kinds of words with
certain kind of attributes and the same
can be said for names too for example
studies show that girls with more
stereotypically feminine names
are more likely to conform to gender
stereotypes and are less likely to major
in sciences and maths compared to girls
with more androgynous names whilst
people with uncommon names are more
likely to enter into unusual careers and
often have a more creative and open
mindset of course it's difficult to
pinpoint cause and effect here do people
with unusual names
favor unusual careers because their
names make them predisposed to seek out
the unorthodox or our parents who give
their children unusual names
also more likely to give them an unusual
upbringing that makes them less inclined
to spend the next 40 years being an
accountant either way having an uncommon
name isn't always a positive thing
particularly for men it's been linked to
higher levels of male mental health
disorders and loneliness
studies have also shown that students
with less common names are often given
lower grades for the same quality of
work compared to those with more common
ones these are all things you might want
to think about when it comes to naming
your child but something you have rather
less control over is your child's
surname which can also have a small but
measurable impact on their performance
in school a study carried out by
professors zacks and corley from the
university of colorado showed that
teachers are more likely to think of
students with surnames at the top of the
alphabet
as clever
compared to those with names at the
bottom possibly because they're used to
seeing those names at the top of lists
and registers students can easily
internalize these biases and it seems
that those with names at the top of the
alphabet regularly rate themselves as
being more successful than those with
names at the bottom
the impacts of this so-called
alphabetism
reach far beyond the school gates too
for example one study found that people
with x y and zed surnames are more
impulsive shoppers which kind of makes
sense if you spent your entire childhood
at the back of the queue a more serious
example can be seen in hospitals where
one study found doctors spend around
four minutes longer discussing the cases
of patients with names at the beginning
of the alphabet
compared to those of names at the end
in most academic disciplines authors of
research papers are ordered in terms of
the size of their contribution to the
study meaning the main author comes
first but in some subjects particularly
economics the authors are listed
alphabetically that might seem like a
fairly inconsequential difference but
the effect appears to be pretty
pronounced not only is it easier to
remember the author whose name appears
first on a publication
but to anyone who's used to
contribution-based ordering systems it
looks like those of names earlier in the
alphabet have played a bigger role in
the study than they necessarily have
as a result economists with names near
the top of the alphabet are a little
more likely to hold high-ranking
positions in university departments
become fellows of the econometric
society and even win nobel prizes and it
isn't just how alphabetically challenged
your name happens to be that can have a
negative impact on your prospects a 2003
study found that people with
traditionally white sounding names were
50 more likely to be invited for
interviews than those with traditionally
black sounding names even when their
qualifications were identical as
depressing as it may be to think that
your name appears to be holding you back
in life there is at least a fairly easy
solution you can change it and more and
more people are choosing to do exactly
that in 2015 85 000 people legally
changed their names in the uk alone
although i'm guessing most of those
weren't attempting to influence their
name-based destiny the biker gang leader
john rothwell changed his name to king
arthur uffa pendragon because he
believed himself to be the reincarnation
of the legendary ruler beezow doodoo
zuppety
chose his new name to reflect his
infinite love for the universe and
probably marijuana
and henry schiff became henry lizard
lover
because
well he really likes lizards changing
your name is in fact so easy that asda
worker greg lewis became dr pasty
smasher omelette just to win a bet
and simon smith woke up after a few too
many beers with the new identity of
bacon double cheeseburger one subsection
of society that loves a good name change
of a weekend are celebrities for peter
gene hernandez aka bruno mars it was to
avoid racial biases and stereotyping but
for others it was just to add a
sprinkling of star factor karen elaine
johnson and norma jean mortensen just
don't have the same level of pizzazz as
whoopi goldberg and marilyn monroe
names are of course only a small factor
in shaping our lives and i should
probably point out that all of the
name-based trends i talk about in this
video emerge only as small statistical
differences from very large data sets
you aren't destined to become a failure
as an economist just because your
surname happens to be zimmerman you
aren't guaranteed to be a straight a
student because your surname's archer
and you can get yourself an amazing job
no matter what your surname is or where
you come from
still
it is kind of interesting to wonder how
life might have turned out differently
had you ended up with a different name
thanks for watching
good news you can now pre-order my new
book bread and circuses what did the
romans ever do for us
it's a wild and witty journey for a
thousand years of unexpected roman
history
told in a refreshing way and packed full
of incredible and unbelievable stories
copies are selling out fast so pre-order
yours today to lock it in
thank you